[Music]
on the faculty chair for market motovan
simply learned I took a quick peek at
the attendee list and it's great to see
so many of you back for webinars I saw
you know one of the names are recognized
when we used to run the market moto
webinars or from the the workshops on
the average workshops so today we're
going to talk about you know when the
best practices fail and this is sort of
a fun subject because I mean sort of
look at best practices and what they are
all right we need to look at what are
best practices and then the reasons that
we sometimes have problems with them
which we'll get into each each type such
as simplifying complex problem use some
resource constraints failures due to
exceptions and then we'll get into some
QA
so first off we say what is a best
practice well you know industry standard
best practice basically says that it's
an accepted way of being effective but
the problem we get into the sort of
excessive ish ins is what one person
thinks of best practice may not be
someone else but we can ask a real
simple question and say who loves broad
match I've asked this to too many
audiences right and at some places
everyone's like I will use it we love it
other places people think it's sort of
like a horrible horrible experience and
that modified is much better there's
some real deep opinions over something
as innocuous as what do you think a
prime match and we'll come back later to
why some people think it's great and why
others really don't like it so the
question that practices who defines this
right and this is where a lot of
confusion stems from or we can look at
something like a keyword guide from
Google and they put in the best
practices use broad match we can look at
an industry publication like peep see
here oh and one of the most common
mistakes they call out is using broad
match so again we are Mac we have a
problem so we're going to go through
some of these issues that people are
into where they're following best
practices and they fail and look at why
that happens so when we think of why
they fail are generally one of three
really common areas but it's taking a
very complex problem and trying to put a
very simple solution on it other times
it's a resource constraint and then
finally sometimes there are just
exceptions to the rule so let's first
look at some simplifying complex
problems areas so we've all heard this
you know advice before your keywords
don't work delete them I mean I'm pretty
sure this is something if I looked at
someone and said hey just delete all
your bad keywords they would say okay
that
it's very reasonable so this account the
the number of keywords with conversions
was about 50 where it's a very small
number compared to their total keywords
which is almost 1100 looked at their
spend almost all their span was up these
small sets of keywords and of course two
other conversions came from it so they
went into their account like they were
told by someone they selected all
keywords with no conversions the past
twelve months and they hit delete
and then time went by and as time went
by their conversions dropped and dropped
and dropped
so this advice led to a very
hard-hitting account that took a lot of
downfall now here was the problem great
we all hear the word attribution
management and what does that mean well
another way of looking at is sort of
assistant keywords so when they looked
at how people searched in their industry
and there happened to be in the the
florist industry with actually half
flowers that people buy not fur to give
away at Valentine's or something but to
plant in their garden so everyone search
for things like how to plant roses
raising tulips something very generic
and they would see this company's ad it
was a nursery they'd read about the
flowers then later on usually two to
four weeks later they starts company
name and bought so all conversions came
from brands but without the generic
searches no one searches for brand and
so what happened is they basically
deleted all the generic words which is
how people found them initially before
they could search for the brand and so
if you have keywords that aren't
performing right it's important to say
are they not performing due to our
attribution model if you're using
last-click may may not look like they're
performing but they're driving the
searches that lead to the conversions
and here's another one where the company
was focused on phone calls and so they
looked at how many calls they get per
day I said okay Monday is great days
Thursday's great day the other days and
not quite as good it made an answer the
phone on the weekends they looked at
their their cost per conversion their
conversion rates or calls per day and
they added bid modifiers so they could
increase obviously their calls and make
a really good CPA
and so after adding bid modifiers their
calls drop significantly in Monday's
dropped a little bit on Tuesdays
Thursdays and Fridays little bit better
but did not make up their huge drop and
say look and they said well this makes
no sense we added this here's been
modifier in Monday and we got less calls
well they also had remove themselves
from weekend searches they happen to be
in the b2b industry so we went back into
the analytics and said okay when our
people really engage with our website so
what's our conversion rates on what
paper downloads or on visits where
someone spent at least three minutes on
the site and when they looked at that
information it turned out sunday was
their number one day this is actually
common in b2b where once it has Friday's
Friday afternoon that web might as well
be dead everyone goes home early they're
looking at bars are going to if they
want to do that night
right now the searches happen on Sundays
so for them when they out of those bid
modifiers
they said Sunday we have no calls we
should make our modifiers - 100% they
get rid of all those researchers on
Sundays that were calling them Monday
morning and so again things like bid
modifiers looking a call that is very
useful to do but just note sometimes
there are delays between searches and
when action takes place and if you're
only looking at when the action takes
place you may be missing the bigger
picture of when you're initially or
found
here's another best practice a free knee
Commerce you should bid by ROI or rose I
don't think many people would argue with
that as the best practice now this
company was not sending bids by any kind
of logic their logic was to to look at
their keyword bids and say well we're in
a low position for that and it's got
some conversions we should raise that
bid or you know we're in a really high
position for this our CPA is going up a
lot on it we should lower bid and so
their bids were kind of done based on
how they felt about their conversions
and their robots numbers without any
rules behind it so they implemented bid
rules they said if it gets more than 100
conversions a week we're going to use
last seven days of data if it gets more
than I'm Hanukkah versions a month so
things are longer you lost 30 days data
if if it's something that we suffer a
few over years last 90 days data justice
that it will bid rule based on return
I've spent so they put into some
simplistic ROAS rules they get way
better than their sort of guessing bids
and their orders went down and the
Roloffs went down they went well that
makes no sense we're now bidding based
upon actual rules why and this should be
very consistent now why is this so
inconsistent
so this company has has quite a few
different parts they sell but when they
sell them they generally fall into one
of two big buckets one a small purchase
order orders under $500 that's 4,500
their orders or is over $10,000 right
which makes up a whole lot of those 500
our orders and they only got a hundred
two of those per month now when they
looked at it though what happened is
look at how predictable are your sales
so in their case of those 10,000 orders
at 102 that came from 87 different
keywords in other words rarely did a
keyword gets to large orders and if it
did it probably didn't the following
month now orders over 500 what happens
is they have roughly 10 conversions per
keyword orders over 500 but they have
4,500 of those are only 250 keywords so
they're high there are high order um
number with the under 500 is very
predictable they're large or is very
unpredictable and so that was one of the
issues they ran into is that bid rules
are based upon predictable repeat
behavior because they're large orders
were unpredictable behavior bid rules
wouldn't accommodate that kind of
information but they realized is that
they weren't really robust bidding by
keyword what they looked at their
overall K here's how much revenue we
usually make per month we don't know
which orders are going to be huge
numbers and what should be small same
keywords could lead to both a large
order and a small order since it well
really we just need to bid by CPA cost
per acquisition and then see how the
large and small order fall into and as
long as we're getting all the small ones
and those large random has come in as
well they keep coming in will actually
make more money so they switched from
robots to CPA bidding and this fixed all
our problems we get cpa 2z leads on
numbers raelia numbered ecommerce unless
you have unpredictable ecommerce
behavior where your top orders are very
sporadic and they're random how they
occur
now here's another company they they've
been online advertising for a very long
time they are a small company in the
landscaper space and so they're based
out of Washington DC and years ago right
back in 2011 they looked at where do our
customers live they took theirs they're
the zip code data off their billing
information they said we're going to
target these users exactly in our
account and it worked well then over the
years they kept getting less orders and
less orders and less orders new one
all right why are we getting so many
less orders when we still have tied bit
positions we haven't changed that much
what's the behavior change that we're
missing and so when we look at at DC
specifically
location targeting across the whole
world there's a lot more accurate now
than it was seven eight years ago more
people are searching on phones of course
now than I was before
in all of those of you who live in
Chicago or Los Angeles or London to
think you had bad community traffic it's
actually DC is the worst and so what
happened right is previously most people
were searching at home for landscaper
now people are searching at work on
their phones for landscapers so here is
sometimes the balance right so they went
ahead and added downtown DC which they
do not service they won't come into DC
to landscaping they only do out in
Virginia and they added it now their
orders went up but so do their cost per
acquisition right so they're sepia
course went up because they're not
reaching people who live in Maryland
live in a different state completely who
just commute to that city so they have a
couple options they could say well we
really want to lower our CPA and so we
could remove the district from this and
our CPAs would go down and our orders
would go down or we can pay for these
commuters our CPA will go up a little
bit but our orders will be significantly
higher so this is one of those there's
not a right or wrong scenario here right
this is what is your volume capacity so
what happens if they add it all you see
it actually breached their volume
capacity so what they did instead is
okay this is our Virginia campaign this
is on this is our our high budget
because we know that this area is where
people live that we serve and but it
does not make up enough volume to keep
every one of our people constantly going
so then here is some more budgets we're
going to put into the DC downtown region
where we know that we're not going to be
everyone a harm some time we don't want
to be there hum some time because it
increases
above our volume capacity so they put
some budget there to supplement what
they can't get by advertise the outer
suburbs so we've all heard take your
best ad right in search and this is a
global average which means sometimes the
numbers are way higher sometimes way
less in search when you pause down
usually to your top ad you'll see and
you've got three or more ads in an ad
group and you actually have testicle
significance you'll often see an
increase in more than 20% clicks and
conversions remarketing is different
remarketing someone has been to your
website they know your offer they know
what they're getting back into and so
what this company is they had five ads
running and they pause down to one now
one add their absolute best ad had a
lower conversion rate than the blended
numbers of all the top five and has a
lower CTR and this is something you need
to remarketing we're in search rarely
will one person that see your exact same
ad over and over again because why would
you search for the same thing for four
days in a row remarketing people often
see your ad more often and so it's
actually fine it's better to have three
or four even five different offers
rotating so that if offer one into the
users like and that's not really
compelling reason for me to buy this
product or service and they see the
second or third one think oh yeah that's
a good reason
and so with remark and you're often
better keeping a few different offers
running as opposed to pausing down to
your absolute best number one which is
different than search by by quite a bit
so let's go out to resource constraints
so this is one where best practice may
overwhelm resources so it's not that you
don't know the best practice it's that
you don't want to implement it because
it would overwhelm what your what your
capacity
susannah airline company who came to us
and this company flies from 40 cities to
40 cities there in six countries and
five different languages so we think 40
cities to 40 cities then you got a
reversal 40 and then you can have ads
that say from the city name to city name
from airport code airport code from City
MD airport code from airport name to
city name and the the numbers get pretty
significant pretty fast and so their
question really was right if we have
keywords like Orlando to Munich flights
or Munich to Rome flakes can we put in
just the city they're flying to we put
in the word you know from the city
they're leaving from we have to put in
both the originating city and the
destination city because if you can put
in just to the city they're going to
write all said you keep your ad groups
down much much smaller as soon as you
have to do the the destination and the
originating city you've essentially
increased all your ad groups by 40 fold
so they ran a simple a test right I mean
it's not simple it was 10,000 a groups
or so but it was what if we do two city
what if you do from city and city to
city
turns out putting both names in there
whether leaving phone whether going to
was significantly better so okay we get
it we need to put both in which means
broad matches off the table modified
broad matches off the table because they
don't cover what orders which means it's
only exact in phrase match for the
entire account now then they said well
what if someone just puts in cheap
flights to Orlando or flights to Munich
we don't know where they're coming from
so in and you know our earlier test site
it was best to put Sevilla city so what
if we make these campaigns set to
individual geographies and then because
we know where they're leaving from
assuming it's where they're searching
from then we can make the ads their city
name too
so they want to fly too even though they
never told us their actual where they're
located right so they again ran the ad
test and turns out yep guessing someone
city and flights is a good idea
now this means we do the math every city
should have at least fourteen thousand
four hundred ad groups and that's a lot
all right when you start doing that by
40 cities so it's some more right what
happens if we do airport names or city
names or airport codes and they did a
lot of different types of tasks to see
how they should organize a simple
campaign which is we fly from 40 cities
to 40 cities then that's the original
question right turns out based on the
testing data they needed 360,000 ad
groups they are four people one of them
is more on the analytic side than on the
adwords side and the Bing side so
120,000 ad groups a person they said we
can't manage that like so what do we do
here when we know it's best practice we
can't do it right and so then we said
okay we're and don't read all the
details here this illustration this is
the actual build but said okay what
cities don't have that much traffic
rates that we could say okay these
cities they're pretty low in total
conversions so we don't have to make
14400 groups for these cities because
they're pretty low number these are the
ones we want to make that sort of
combination size for it and so that way
we can say where do you really not lose
much by not going to perfect right now
the next question was though right this
this is a good CEO CFO question if I
hire someone else will I make more money
than when I'm paying that person in
salary that's the a fantastic question
right to ask when you realize you can't
do things perfectly
we're taking a sub optimal performance
in this thing what do I need to do to
around a salary versus return standpoint
so we looked at the rules and said okay
how do we make this simple yet we go
ahead and do this at scale so if the
city gets more than 500 conversions a
year it gets to campaign what Arlis say
is bid modifier only they're only going
to use dynamic remarketing to forget
some of the others for now right and
then for every I think it was six
campaigns I could be wrong on the number
they add then they go ahead and hire a
new person for it because it makes sense
on their returns vs. salary and so
that's sometimes say we can't do it all
right that's fine so let's cut up the
worst stuff first and then put rules
that we can show to our our you know CFO
CEO who whatnot because if we can do
this this cost us this much and here's
what we get in return and that way you
can even put salary our on organization
structures
another question clothes variants
especially now that the change to match
types happened where you can have an
exact match that shows for plural shows
for singular shows reverse orders so
maintaining true the old style exact
match if they only want to show for
these exact characters being typed in
it's really difficult so this company
right they looked at their data and and
they're in wholesale restaurant supplies
and if someone searches for something
like blue widgets singular right they
have a high conversion rate 2.9 but an
$81 average order if they search the
plural version of the same word the
conversion rate drops a little bit their
average order value goes to 673 that's
your genetic difference that singular s
makes a huge difference in how much
they're willing to bid for that keyword
so best practice says right here we
should stop and we should manage our ad
groups singular versus plural now any of
you who managing really granular
accounts like that is a mass and that's
why that shouldn't stop there right with
the best practice they should say is
what's the opportunity cost so if you're
a small account you're spending a
thousand bucks a month no what you're
going to probably ignore that because
your value gained versus how much more
money you're going to make is so tiny
compared to this sheer amount of work
it's going to take you're not going to
see the rewards now if you're a large
accounts right you're spending fifty
thousand a hundred thousand a million
dollars a month and you see Wow okay we
get a hundred orders of you know these
twenty singular versus floral products a
month by splitting that how we're going
to make another hundred thousand dollars
a month it's worth actually managing
that way so again with some of these
it's not this is the right way right
it's that this is best but our our
return is going to
so minimal by doing vast we can do good
enough or hey this is best and if we
manage the best we really notice the
difference we should go ahead and make
those changes
so another one that I commonly see still
to this day we've all heard of the
discovery manage sometimes called the
alpha-beta campaign now with this
campaign structure the goal is to have
one campaign where you've got a water
broad match for modified broad match
keywords and then you run those and if
the keyword converts you make it an
exact match in that first campaign you
make it a negative exact match in the
first campaign you add it to the second
campaign is an exact match keyword
because your second campaign that man is
campaign about beta campaign is going to
be where your real conversions come from
right and so this is a really common
work for me alpha beta manage discovery
proper workflow now I watched the agency
put this into play and for their top
client it did not take long term in a
row to reach out and say hey alright so
we want manage team initially right now
managing I call hero terms and we
started managing them with this with
this overall structure and our
conversions dropped almost 21 not 2100
in roughly a month that's a big drop
from theoretically having a more
organized structure now this is that
this is usually a process definition
problem so when you looked at their
keywords this was happening are you
showing no because people don't search
enough right this is so what they needed
to do right is not just say this words
got to conversion we make it an exact
match they need to do is say all right
we need to add this keyword to our our
manage campaign only when we're not
going to run - low volume problems when
we add them so they defined what this
term should be instead of saying we add
any clear that conversion we say if it's
not at least 35 impressions and 2
conversions a month for three
consecutive months now we know it keeps
converting
and it keeps having enough impressions
it will consistently show as soon as
they put that process definition into
place they got the benefit to the
campaign structure right the conversions
went up and so when you have processes
in place this is when this happens we do
this when this happens we do this make
sure those processes are well defined I
can't count the ages I've walked into
where they have defined processes and
you sit down with analyst one and you
look at how they do it and you sit down
with analysts who you look at how they
do it analyst to relook at how they did
and so forth and while they all have
quote the same process the way it's
implemented is often dramatically
different because some of the data
points weren't defined and what that
process looks like
now there are times there's just
exceptions right to the rule so I think
we've all heard this before
don't send all your traffic to the
homepage right this is usually PPC 101
find the most relevant page for keyword
that's the traffic sugar now I can't
show this client's website but I can
show two very similar ones so one it's
in the nanny it's in the nanny space so
who's someone you're hiring to come in
your house and look at your kids and so
the one was look at home page like the
semantic source page we get there you
see okay front a job I'm hire a
caregiver and hey we do background
checks on everyone before they get to
our database great second one is hey if
you're in Chicago you need a nanny
here's some resumes that people who are
in our system you join you get access to
Kate and Sabrina and so forth who will
come right to your house and look after
your kids so of course they looked at
their site and what while if someone's
in Chicago we should use that that kind
of a Geo page with Los Angeles we should
use a las angeles resumes and stuff with
it so forth
so they didn't use their homepage right
there is no geo pages and then they want
well what if we actually test our
homepage right we don't want to just
make us some solution test this so they
test it initially and in their cost per
conversion was higher their homepage
than the city landing pages right which
is exactly what you would expect the
conversion rate was high in the city
landing pages now thing is this is
aggregate data across networks which
overall aggregate data is useless
you must always segment data at once
sometimes twice to get to the real heart
of what's happening so they segment us
by search and display
and they looked at searched some went
Wow for search our conversion rate for
our homepage is almost double those city
specific pages on display it's the exact
opposite they have run this test
probably the first time I ran this test
was 2005 I believe they have run this
test three times a year since then so
it's 36 times over 12 years our home
page is still best for search they spend
a couple hundred thousand dollars a
month every search click ghost or home
page display the city pays our
differently they work better for display
now when you think about the user right
so if someone is searching for nanny
services
this person has thought about this who
is coming into my house to take care of
my kids
right so family money time right the
things that we want part of we have to
be really careful as marketers right
this affects one of the big three family
right so on display network it's not so
the same right someone's reading the
article about their favorite you know
football scores or you know recipes and
they see this play ad if someone who
will come to their house and watch their
kids for them like wow that's like a
great idea and they click on Oh people
in my local area so it's a very
different mindset and so sometimes we'll
see very different behavior on sites by
network and so when you do your tasks
you should always always even landing
pages segment out search versus display
now this sounds like something you'd
never want to do right we want to lower
our quality score on purpose
so this company we look at conversion
rates by Quality Score for the same
keyword
their conversion rates are higher when
their quality score is lower now that
sounds very counterintuitive
now they happen to be in an industry
where there's a lot of b2b and a
tremendous amount of b2c searches for
the same keyword so they sell safety
gates so there's two types of safety
gates there's one cost you know 20 30
bucks that you keep kids and pets I have
an air your house the other one starts
at three thousand dollars goes up to a
few million dollars meant for industrial
plants and factories so if you look at
the ones in blue those are all b2b they
say industrial safety gates OSHA
compliance right free quotes so this is
really different so all three of those
can very quickly raise their quality
scores they take out the word industrial
they take out the word OSHA compliance
powder coating and all of a sudden it'll
look like a B to B to C and they'll get
lots of clicks so they're quick the rate
will go up a lot their convert their
Clause scores will follow and go up as
well and the conversion rates will
plummet so it in areas B to B being a
really good a good example
you're often better off with lower
quality scores because they're
pre-qualifying users from ever wanting
to click on your ads in the first place
now speed is a really funny thing speed
does not matter the perception of speed
is all that matters
so if there was an airport and the
airport had this problem everybody
complains that it took too long to get
their bags when they wind it so the
airport they made some adjustments to
baggage the hyper baggage people and
they got down to the industry standard
for small airport eight minutes the
complaints didn't change everyone
complained it takes too long to get my
bags to look at it okay what does
someone do when they get off the plane
well they it's a small airport they get
off the plane they walk about a hundred
steps and the rat baggage so they spend
30 seconds getting to baggage seven and
a half minutes waiting so the airport
went well ha we've got these terminals
that we don't really use we're going to
move the gates over there so move the
gates to a different terminal where the
user gets off the plane they spend six
minutes walking it to the baggage they
spend two minutes waiting for the
baggage complaint stopped
the users time from getting off the plan
to get in their bags was eight minutes
that didn't change which change was
perception of how long it took to get
their bags all right so it's not speed
that matters it's the perception of
speed that matters this was a site it's
a database lookup site so you go to it
you enter your name you enter your zip
code you choose the data types you want
and the system starts looking up data
right and so they could show their
results instantaneously
but they want well what happens if we
spin a wheel that says we're looking at
no these hundred things and these
hundred things and these hundred things
and and write a little banner of
benefits at the same time we get better
conversions by appearing to work harder
for the user so they ran this test in
15-second into increments
from zero seconds to 215 seconds and it
turns out around the two and a half
minute weight point was their best
conversion rates they're not doing
anything they just have a little spinny
wheel it sits there he goes searching
databases this to this did you know blah
blah blah spinning blah blah blah but
people get invested in time so what
happened with people initially when this
takes too long they left all right that
a quick drop-off in conversions they
waited longer when some there's a
threshold but once someone passed it
they were so invested in waiting it was
more painful to leave and think about on
the service then it is wait a few more
seconds right so it's important is also
think about that perception of time to
your users in certain cases mobile yeah
fastest is very very useful sometimes
it's good to think about what their
perception of how things are loading as
opposed to real items right load time is
one of those funny things that if you
load your top elements very quickly rest
your page could take a really long time
to load but the user perceives it as
fast because it's hot visual elements
loaded first so is a company who you
know we follow the advice we started
with right they looked at other broad
mass keywords and they changed it all to
modify broad so all right we give in we
understand everyone hates broad batch
we're going to go to modify broad match
let's see what happens
well their conversion rates have go up
their conversions dropped significantly
once they switched now broad match
there's quite a few things that that
modified broad does not one of them
being matching the multilingual queries
so this company they're they're
obviously an Arabic company and they
have a lot of queries that are include
both English or French and Arabic and so
modified broad doesn't show across
language types broad match will match
two queries that include both languages
so what's interesting is on when we
asked you promised you liked broad match
they're further than natural language is
from English the more people like broad
match usually the closer their natural
language is to English the less they
like it but there's a lot of good uses
of broad match right whether it's the
longtail allah''says targeting bid
you're only reaching users in your
audience list research right there's a
lot of good uses depends on why you're
using it so before we're about to get to
questions but you know best practices
they are that way for a reason they're a
great starting place if you're newer
your intermediate user you need
something to get started best practices
are the way to go because they work for
most people but they may not always work
for you and the three main reasons they
don't work is due to simplifying complex
problems they may be ignored for good
reason for resource constraints or
actual exceptions those are common but
they do exist all right I'm going to see
if dan has rejoined us and we can do a
little bit of questions and answers if
we're good on over so they are you back
with us better I am thank you Brad that
was great so everyone I don't know if
you were given this instruction before
but if you'd be happy to ask a question
then feel free to either pop it in chat
to us or in the Q&A function which is
there both
upper right hand corner of your window
there and we just have a we have one
question coming in so far asking about
and then you mentioned about the the
language differences and and broad match
catching all that but but Gary would
like to know what other differences and
best practices are there between
international campaigns and domestic
campaigns so can you because he's had
trouble taking the best practices that
have worked for him in the US and then
tried to apply those to the rest of the
world and got completely different
different results do you have any other
advice yeah that's a great question
right so why so I will make sure for
everyone on the call though we catch the
languages one correct right so when you
choose your languages that is based on
operating system and browser preferences
and so forth it is not based upon the
language the user searches with right so
my computer is obviously English if I go
to Germany and I'm at google.de and I
search in English even if you have
English keywords if your language
setting is German I want say your ads so
it's very useful especially in Europe to
open up language settings geo-targeting
is not quite as accurate in a lot of
European cities like London London is
something like what a third of the UK
population but it's not super accurate
there same for another one's yet Germany
in in France it's highly accurate so
sometimes you do have you know in the US
you really in certain areas like Chicago
right you really can target a mile
around a business and and you'll be
pretty decent with that it doesn't work
nearly as well when you go
internationally um the other thing with
international it's interesting is like
one of our other attacks we did we have
this where
the language helps you understand if
someone's a tourist or a local so for
instance I work with a a car rental
company and if someone searches in a
language not native to the country
they're generally a tourist so if you
search in German in Italy right you're
probably a tourist and for them they're
very UNAM you know car rentals Fiat
better conversion rates right than
someone searching in Italian in Italy
where if you are your landscaping
services that's obviously not true it's
a little bit different I'm sure there
are others those are the ones that just
immediately pop up on top of my head
great thanks those are those are some
some wonderful points well that is
actually the other questions were pretty
easy to answer offline as it was so and
by the way everyone we will be sharing
the recording of this webinar with you
so be checking your your email in about
a week or so force another message from
us and feel free to share as much as you
like rad is there anything else you'd
like to like to add no right I think
that's I think we covered a lot of good
stuff it's you know best practices on
the sand of them
I obviously write a lot of them and and
but they're starting places for many
people they're also ending places but
just because someone says is the best
way to do it does not mean that applies
to you so it's a good idea it's always
you know check your assumptions on
occasion just to make sure that the base
of assumptions you're building things on
actually does apply to to your industry
your account and so forth that's great
it's a wonderful closing point because
testing testing never gets out at all
never
so thank you everyone for joining us and
we will be sending an email with a link
to the recording to you later thanks
again Brad this was really informative
and we'll talk to you again again soon
have a great evening or day everyone
thank you Dan bye
[Music]